Eliza Clarke you know has now spent so
much time around the grounders lived
amongst the grounders you know just how
much you know has she maybe she hasn't
yeah oh she has obviously taken on some
of their physical characteristics and
clothing how much does she feel
comfortable with them now versus you
know her people or her people with ARC
well let me tell you the clothing is not
comfortable no I think she feels very
comfortable I mean especially through
LexA she she she feels like she's a part
of them and wants to protect them as
much as she wants to protect the sky
crew we are a crew now that's that's the
thing we're the 13th clan
I mean the ice nation will work on that
but they don't really like that very
much but but I think that it's been I
mean it's been a crazy transformation in
in season three four o'clock just kind
of understanding the ways of the
grounders and and and wanting to
amalgamate our worlds for good for the
for the good of the human race and
especially now with this new threat I
think it's more important now more than
ever
mm-hmm and in with you mentioned the
fact that Kane is is a leader which he
definitely is in a very natural one and
seems to be very skilled one but he's
often you know last season he kind of
didn't want to just take that role on
which she ended up kind of backfiring on
him with Pike but this he also is at
time as I look back at season two he
kind of acquiesced a bit more to Clark
as a leader when Abby wasn't really
ready for that how does he feel about
you know Clark and the fact that she's
sort of risen up this leader figure
almost alongside him at some points I
think I didn't give it up to to Pike I
think foolishly I thought that I would
win the election and I lost and I blame
Bellamy
so it's how do I feel well we'll see now
there is a there's a void in leadership
certainly in polis and there's no
there's no elected Chancellor so I think
season episode 1 will answer that
question because we need to fill that
void very quickly yeah mm-hmm I think
just to help just to chip in on that for
a second Eliza Clark the season sort of
owns for power you know she's only did
she saved the world last year she's done
enough I pulled a few levers he's pulled
a few lever one too many but yeah so she
said I think Kane and Abby as well
recognize that like they may recognize
that they're dealing with someone
special and it's her time you know it's
her time to to do it again really ah
and I think it's about time that we
spoiled something for everyone it turns
out that um
Kane is my dad that's it that's kind of
when she I cuz the you know in in the
first episode season one I was meant to
be somebody's father uh but they still
might be you somebody else's father in
the script um I don't know if Jason ever
made that public did you even make that
no I don't know if ever going to tell
them yes it's Noah it's not true but yes
it's true that it was real to happen but
we it's not the case he's not her folks
and I am no longer that is that
confirmed
oh you can laughing did you say no
because I was supposed to be Marie's dad
yeah and always and I was all the way
through I should be Bob's dad the story
her story is balls are balls
great Bob and Ian col h of the son and
dad like every day on set by the hay
season two we started messing around and
i said i'm gonna play a lie
I'm your dad none even okay dad okay son
there's that scene in the pilot where
you're looking at the iPod or the that's
right that may play Octavia's face was
on it and then and you were looking at
it longingly a little bit right and then
in walks CC the vanished girlfriend of
Queens and it felt a little like you
were looking at a girlfriend while your
other girl I see right it was it was
that creepy I got it Octavia the
daughter's your girlfriend how many
really good mom is all about dad the
whole hundred alternate-reality going on
here 100 slash Jerry Springer free let
me ask about the fact that Octavia's
clearly tried you know she's had such a
struggle to fit in and she thought it
was with the grounders and that didn't
work and she ended up back with her
people but never really comfortable is
that feeling more extreme than ever now
given everything that's happened yeah I
think she felt like her home was with
the grounders and then she just felt
like her home was wherever Lincoln was
and then it's been throughout that loss
in her self-discovery in the past two
seasons on who she is and what she does
to fit in and Rose really helped her
hone in on you know home is in here in
your heart
um so she's really sort of figured out
who she is in in that department and
again and what she's good at she was
like you know we'll Ravens the mechanic
and Clark's the doctor what am i who am
i you know and she really like found her
home within herself and becoming a
warrior and and that's thanks to Lincoln
and Indra definitely and what they got
really like on this show there's such a
big cast so sometimes we don't really
see characters interact together and
then suddenly you do and it's like oh
this is interesting so Lindsey I'm
curious like you know last season for
instance Raven and jaha had some notable
scenes together which was kind of the
first time is that fun for you just as
far as like oh you work with these
people but sometimes you don't directly
work with them and then you get bounced
off that different energy oh definitely
I think it's anytime we get to work with
each other or anyone that we haven't you
know been working with a lot each other
and
their storylines it's exciting it's like
you get a new dude new friend to play
with
I mean Isiah is amazing and he taught me
so much just seeing the way he works in
being exposed to his process so I really
enjoyed it and um you know I love that
we have a big cast so it's it's always a
constant door of a fresh faces and fresh
ideas and fresh art so it's very
exciting
mm-hmm similarly Chris for you it's you
know like Monty and Jasper that was like
the duo for the first couple years and
then in season three you guys were
separated you know from each other for a
lot of that you know as much as people
love that pairing was it also cool for
you to like have the the Monty and Raven
scenes and of course the heartburn Monty
scenes that's a great question Eric well
thank you Chris while I have you all
here quick show of hands who's a fan of
the Monty Harper connection three rows
who's disgusted by like who stomach just
turned thinking about it what to pee you
get out and who's like who's like forget
Harper it's Miller time so what I
thought
okay back to the question um yes I I was
asked this a lot earlier about working
with Lindsay specifically because um I
don't think we'd had we'd had like two
scenes together beforehand and so I told
your mom was dead
yeah give it up that yeah that and so
this this at the end of the season we
had the scene where at the do mom deaf
member too and I was I was feeling very
nervous about it because it was probably
the biggest challenge for me in season 3
and so I so grateful to have Lindsay by
my side because to have someone that you
trust and is so invested
you know like new faces it forces you to
up your game and and and create yourself
in a new way it's it's yeah those are
some of my favorite scenes of season
three mm-hmm no one asked quickly
adjacent about Jasper just because you
know the in the finale he came back out
of the City of Light and there was a
nice touching scene with him and Monty
but a lot of people wondered where
his head was at as he walked out of that
room just how dark things could have
gone yeah that scene actually I wrote
this is some there's been a little bit
of talk about this so I might as well
just admit to the original ending of the
finale spoiler was Jasper comes out of
the city of light and what leaves that
room and goes and blows his brains out
but it was too dark even for me I lived
with that scene in post if by the way I
have to say brilliant scene the boys
crushed it Jasper was amazing Devin was
unreal that's my god I'm here Chris was
so good you were so good in that scene I
don't think anybody will ever see that
scene um but it was really just a
horrible way to leave what was a really
dark season and I just felt it was not
the right ending plus I felt there was
more in the tank for Jasper in terms and
we loved Evans so much that like how
could we let him go really yeah and what
we're gonna really you know I mean
that's that's the truth it just was
something that I in my gut didn't feel
right about and so I cut it and we found
the better anyways mm-hmm
Plus every couple years Devin gets
unkilled on the show he does uncle it's
his annual thing right uh you know
meanwhile though Richard it seems like
to me Murphy is like the most adaptable
character on this show it's like you
wouldn't think that initially but then
it turns out like every situation every
character he has thrown into he somehow
manages to make it work
well he's a smart guy man you guys don't
give him enough credit just cuz he spied
it spelled die wrong like once dumb guy
just didn't go to school properly that's
just the system though ya know he's an
absolutely adaptable guy I mean his
track record shows that he's very he's a
survivor as we've always said and as
Lindsey just whispered to me a cockroach
yeah I'm glad to know what you think of
me a lovable khakhra favorite the
everyone's favorite copy yeah you can't
get him that's not a challenge Jason
yeah a challenge what I think is
interesting about where you are now is
that you are a part of the
like you yeah lunch is great all right
you know for the first time ever
you kept Clark alive was I actually
thanked you for once yeah didn't know
how to take that I was weird for me it
felt it felt weird but it was cool all
right nerd a lot away from me yeah okay
you can sit at the cool kids table
basically that looks exciting now it's
kind of nice to actually be part of the
group and kind of see that see how that
might work out because you guys I I feel
like you owe me a little bit just take
just a tiny bit I don't know but I feel
like me and you were square now though
right even were ever good even steven
okay I don't think so
never mind more debt to be paid um let
me ask Jason about the the season finale
and you know obviously we we got to see
LexA again in that finale and the City
of Light and a very cool sort of return
moment and some big action stuff there
there was a lot going on there as far as
the flame and the City of Light the City
of Light is gone now the flame is still
exist
so is that accessible again is that is
the City of Light accessible is LexA and
the other commanders I would I really
really like to know this prior to her
well the City of Light is gone version
or alleys gone the flame exists of
course and all the minds of the
commanders are in the flames the finale
was designed really from day one we knew
Clarke was going to take the flame we
didn't know the details of it but we
knew Clarke was going to go into the
City of Light she was going to need her
friends in the real world to keep her
alive long enough to take out Ally and
she was going to need help on the inside
too and that that meant LexA so we
always knew LexA was coming back in the
finale we always knew there was going to
be this triumphant romantic emotional
moment and it was designed both to be
that return for that character and a
finale so lex's not coming back to the
show she won't be in season 4 but
ultimately the flame is an important
thing we realize that the flame is a
political artifact as well whoever holds
the flame in lieu of a knife leg right
before it can be put into a night blood
has
we'll see it play itself out that way
this season in a very different
storyline is there still no true
commander I mean there was one but after
some really weird hurt massaging she's
gonna ya know Clark is not the commander
she's not hey des
no there is no commander and there are
no night Bloods that on it that we know
so but there will be night blood scouts
Titus had Scouts out in the world and we
will see one of them and meet one of
them and I it'll be an interesting thing
for her that character when she shows up
in terms of how she's going to deal with
what happened with the flame and who has
the flame and you know what law what is
left of her religion her spirituality
mm-hmm but as an aside Richard was that
one of the weirdest scenes you ever shot
the reaching into someone's chest to
hold the part I'm going to cut you off
there easily for that it was just very
sticky and it felt like it felt like I
keep in mind I don't actually know what
a real heart feels like so I was about
to say it felt like a real heart but
there's and she was playing crossword
wasn't she in between yeah yeah yeah
rhiannon in between takes was just like
doing crossword puzzles
ain't no i posting that day yeah she
wasn't she was honestly I got to say
that that she was a trooper three she
was that she never complained once she
was just laying in a table yeah days cuz
that that that whole sequence that final
sequence was such a like a laboring
thing to shoot in such a big task I was
a huge time
I mean turned out though a lot I do want
to ask you know Clark obviously
everyone's gone through a lot of loss in
this show but Clark sort of history it's
like she lost her father Finn LexA is
this you know hardened her or is it just
made her even more protective as a
person
apparently I have the kiss of death
that's what I've heard recently and yeah
it's I mean it's hot of course it's
hardened her
she'll never be the same she wat she
wasn't the same the second she had to
witness her father being executed and
then from that point on she had to see a
lot lot more and actually execute people
herself so she's hardened but in a lot
of ways I think you know through her
relationships with with with you know
her her group her core group who were
here now and and with LexA and she has
found camaraderie and and doesn't feel
quite as alone as she once did which is
a positive thing
you